عبد السلام حدثنا عن المساعدات التي دخلت
غزه اليوم وعن قمه السلام في القاهره بعد
انتظار طال لايام منذ بدء هذه الحرب على
قطاع غزه والمعبر مغلق فتح اليوم بدخول
اول قافله احتوت على 20 شاحنه وهي ما يقول
الجانب الفلسطيني ووزاره الصحه داخل غزه
بانها لا تكفي لشيء حتى ان المساعدات
الطبيه التي دخلت حتى الان ضمن شاحنتين لا
تحمل ما يكفي وما هو مطلوب من الم
المساعدات الطبيه اللازمه لاجراء العمليات
في هذا الظرف وفي هذه الحرب المستمره على
القطاع ايضا هناك حديث بان لا دخول للوقود
وهو ما يمنعه الجانب الاسرائيلي في حين ان
المتحدثه باسم برنامج الاغذيه العالميه
قالت بان كل المساعدات التي دخلت تحتاج
للوقود للاستفاده منها والا لن يتم
الاستفاده منها بالشكل الامثل الامين
العام للامم المتحده انطونيو جوتيريس كان
بالامس على المعبر وراقب ق ب الوضع من
هناك ومن ثم حضر قمه السلام التي دعا لها
الرئيس المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي وعندما
حملت اسم السلام كان الرئيس المصري قد
تحدث عن خارطه طريق لاعاده احياء مسار
السلام وتحدث ايضا عن الامن القومي المصري
وبانهم لن يسمحوا بتهجير الفلسطينيين ولن
يحدث ذلك على حساب مصر بطبيعه الحال ولن
يسمحوا ايضا بتصفيه القضيه الفلسطينيه وهو
كلام ايضا رد عليه واضاف اليه الرئيس
الفلسطيني الذي قال بانهم لن يذهبوا الى
اي مكان ولن يتركوا الضفه الغربيه واو
قطاع غزه العاهل
الاردني تحدث عن الحكومه الاسرائيليه
الحاليه بانها فضلت خيار الامن على خيار
السلام وهو ما هو غير مقبول وبانهم يصرون
على العوده الى مسار حل الدولتين الذي بات
غير ممكن الان في ظل هذه الحرب
الاسرائيليه على قطاع غزه الامين العام
كما ذكرنا للامم المتحده حضر الاجتماع
وحضره ايضا رئيس مجلس الاتحاد الاوروبي
شارل ميشيل الذي اكد على ضروره حمايه
المدنيين ووقف الحرب وادخال المساعدات
للفلسطينيين المتضررين منها